bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france quel regard est ce que vous
portez sur ces événements qu distille de
la situation dans votre département
alors il ya je pense un point de vue
général c'est qu'on n'a pas su répondre
à la montée de la délinquance des
mineurs en restant dans une certaine
forme de naïveté on est resté sur la
danse de 45 ans prévoyant des selles
d'irresponsabilité qui en fait les met
dans une position inconfortable parce
qu'ils sont exploités par des réseaux
ils sont mis en avant notamment les plus
jeunes et donc plus vulnérables à ces
faits de violence de délinquance décrit
le deuxième phénomène qu'on voit c'est
effectivement le confinement de
nombreuses installations sportives
culturelles des points d'accueil jeunes
sont fermés et ces jeunes se retrouvent
parfois sans structure pour les
accueillir
on voit bien que ces règles sanitaires
qui sont tout à fait justifiées sur le
fond
au bout d'un certain temps ces règles
sanitaires pèse sur le climat de ces
quartiers et puis en essonne prise et le
point que t'être on a un des sites truc
structurel de police il manque 200
policiers par rapport aux autres
départements franciliens j'ai eu
l'occasion dans le cadre du bo la
sécurité d'intercall est de mise de
l'intérieur mais sur ce point on n'est
pas suffisamment entendue aujourd'hui
qu'à votre département et tu oublié par
l'état alors oubliez non mais eu
quelques quelques renforts mais pas pas
suffisamment et c'est vrai qu'on a un
déficit structurel en termes
d'enseignants de policiers mais aussi de
personnels de justice parce que ce que
nous disent les policiers et gendarmes
quand on arrive à un dialogue avec eux
c'est que ce travail de fond est fait
mais les affaires vont pas jusqu'au bout
et notamment les peines soient pas
suffisamment s'initiant tu sois très
partiellement exécuté voir une
difficulté ça c'est un vrai problème est
la réforme une liste de la justice est
proposé aucun de ceux-ci des mineurs
n'est pas non plus satisfaisante il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient
à la sanction adaptée à l'âge mais une
sanction sinon c'est le permis à la
délinquance qui est délivrée par des
ch'ti ce1 suivent un mort ferme et alors
comment est ce que vous vous l'expliquer
cette absence de fermeté de la part de
la justice aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y
a eu une vision de la jeunesse qui est
resté calé à celle de 945 or les jeunes
évoluent énormément
ils sont matures entre guillemets plutôt
sur un son de sujet on voit bien que les
phénomènes de violence il ya à la fois
rx il ya la constitution des mineurs il
ya la partie des stupéfiants cette
violence tend à progresser et on passe
on a une justice qui reste avec dès 1945
à la fois insuffisamment équipées
s'agissant du personnel des réponses à
apporter en terme de peine mais aussi
avec un logiciel est celui de deux
jeunes qui posait pas trop problème ou
en gros en laissant bonnant faisant un
petit rappel doit sa sottise eh bien
aujourd'hui les jeunes c'est autre chose
enfin en tout cas ces jeunes parce qu'on
ne veut pas faire de généralités sur les
jeunes qui se comporte très bien c'est
pas le sujet elle est rentable de
quelques jeunes je pense qu'il faut une
réponse qui est à la fois pédagogique
mais aussi ferme à terme sinon on a vite
à la délinquance encore une fois c'est
un simple ami d'être délinquant si on
n'est pas certain
cette nouvelle fait violence vous venez
de le rappeler à elle n'est pas nouvelle
elle empire à vous entendre l empire de
quelle façon
c'est sur ces dernières semaines on a eu
des tentatives d'enlèvement on a eu des
risques on a eu vendredi un le meurtre
il avait pas 14 ans il est dépassé c'est
un jeune adulte on a eu
il ya quelques semaines deux jeunes
adolescentes de 14 ans qui sont morts
dans des rixes
on voit bien alors en essonne mais
partout en france ce n'est pas que les
soldes on a une montée et ça c'est un
indicateur qui ne trompent pas puisque
sandy qualité qu'un indicateur qui est
fiable depuis des siècles c'est les
homicides
parce que ça on ne triche pas ces
paliers ou dépôt de plainte c'est pas
lié aux consignes du ministère de
l'intérieur du moment les homicides au
monde structurellement depuis quelques
années et ça c'est le signe vraiment
tangible
il monte très forte de la violence merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne alexandre transigera
pas le concept avis départementale de
l'essonne chargée de la sécurité